- So that chapter is hard on me.
It's sort of
traumatic to read it.
Because I struggle with it.
Because I'm in pain
most of the time.
But I know that it's not
helpful to be resentful.
It's better to be grateful.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a clinical psychologist,
a lecturer an author,
and perhaps most importantly,
a man who truly changed
my life for the better
Dr. Jordan Peterson.
Welcome back to
the Rubin Report.
- It's really good
to see you Dave.
- Gosh, well, we connected
for about a minute
before we started this
officially and you said,
boy it's been about two years.
We've we've texted a little bit.
It's been a crazy two years.
It goes without saying.
So before I get into
any of the meat of this,
and I wanna talk
obviously about the...
About the new book
and everything else
I think what's on
everyone's mind
more than anything
is how are you.
Just, how are you?
- Well, I'm at home
and I'm working
about a third of the
time I would say.
I'm working hard on my podcasts
and YouTube discussions.
And I can manage about
two hours of work a day.
And so I'm not in the hospital.
And I'm sharp again,
reasonably sharp, again.
Trying to write again.
I'm planning a new book.
We'll see how that goes.
It's nice to be back.
It's nice to be doing
these discussions.
I've talked to lots
of interesting people
over the last couple of months.
Douglas Murray, Ian
Hazili, [indistinct] Ian...
I'm gonna forget Ian's
last name McGilchrist.
He wrote The master
and His Emissary.
So I'm working a bit and I
have this new book coming out,
as you mentioned, and that's
coming out on the 2nd of March.
So that's interesting and
exciting and stressful.
All of those things.
I hope it's well-received.
I can't evaluate it.
You know, I'm too close
to it to evaluate it.
- Yeah, well, I have no
doubt that there will be
plenty of people evaluating it.
And you've already
sort of dove back
into dealing with the media.
So all that stuff
is kind of common.
But you know obviously
over the last two years
so much has happened,
and it feels like we're
in a different world
and everything else.
And you know, so many people,
they asked me about you.
They asked me about
our time together
and the tour and
everything else.
And truly for me when
people ask me that,
or just when I think
back to that year.
I mean, we did about 120
stops in almost 20 countries.
You did a bunch more that I
couldn't attend even after that.
It feels like a dream to me.
Like that year it was
so intense and wonderful
and magical and sometimes
stressful, sometimes tiring,
whatever it was, but it
was just in the summation.
It was just wonderful.
What do you think back
on mostly about that?
- Well, it seems like
a dream to me too.
You know being the last two
years have been mostly hospitals
for one reason or another.
And I suppose it's
partly dreamlike
because of the vast contrast
between 2018 and
then 2019 and 2020.
I mean, that tour was
an amazing experience.
It was so positive, apart
from the odd press blast.
Which were islands of
negativity in a sea
of what was positive.
It was really something to
travel from city to city
and to talk to all those people.
And yeah, it was an
amazing experience.
And I'd certainly
like to do it again.
If I could gather
myself together
I know Tammy too had a really...
She thought it was
a great adventure.
And I thought we
worked well together.
You and I, it was nice to
have some levity associated
with all the seriousness.
That's a good combination.
If you could pull it off.
It was so nice to
see all those people
who were trying to put
their lives together.
And such a remarkable
range of people.
I don't wanna use
the word diverse
because it's been completely
poisoned of course.
But there were every sort
of person in our audiences
and they'd all come together
for positive reasons,
as far as I could tell.
It sure felt that way.
It was so nice to
meet people too.
And they were always so
friendly and welcoming.
You know, when you say
I've been so fortunate
in the response that
I've received from people
who've watched my YouTube videos
or listened to the podcast
or read the book.
It's really sustained
me, kept me going.
- Yeah, it was great.
- It was a ridiculous
experience.
It was unbelievable.
- That's it?
- It was a ridiculous
experience.
People ask me this
too and I actually
don't have a good
answer for this.
But beyond just the
occasional hit piece
and the strange things
the New York times,
Enforcement [indistinct]
and the rest of that,
was there anything negative?
I mean, there were
some emotional stuff
that was happening
and obviously you found
out that Tammy was ill
and thank God she's better now.
And you were having-
- She says hello
by the way Dave.
- Oh, please send
her send her my love.
Mine and David's please do.
But beyond some of that...
The hit piece stuff and
some of the health stuff
that you started to deal
with and that Tammy was ill.
Do you remember anything
that was negative?
I truly don't.
It was like every day
that we went somewhere
it was more love, more people
putting their lives together.
And the stories, just
the incredible stories
that we heard everywhere.
- Yeah, well, and we did the
meet and greets afterwards
and I also really liked that.
I only 10 to 15 seconds
with each person
or couple or family
whatever it was,
but that was all
extremely positive too.
So, no, I mean,
I've tried to figure out
why I've become so ill.
There's a variety of reasons.
Some of it's associated
with this familial proclivity
for depression, no doubt.
But I don't believe that
it was a consequence
of certainly not of that tour.
I mean, and I've always liked
my whole life since I was 25.
I've gone flat out.
I like that.
I like to live like that.
To work 15 or 16
hours a day flat out.
And I mean, I did
learn how to do that.
I thought and be
able to sustain it.
And so, no, my health
wasn't 100% on that tour.
That was probably
a prodrome drama
for everything that
happened later.
But I really don't
think it had anything
to do with the tour.
Now all the controversy
that swirled around me,
that's a different thing.
That has been
extremely stressful.
And I don't really know
how to calibrate that.
I watch people on Twitter
and if they say something
and 20 people mob them,
that's usually enough
to really set them back
on their heels.
And generally people apologize
and well make things
worse often by doing that.
But it doesn't take many
people to go after you
before it has a real
pronounced emotional effect.
And that happened a lot
and it was somewhat...
I can't really
understand it exactly,
why it happened so much.
And I'm sure that had
some effect on me.
Because when it happens now
it certainly wallops me.
We had a run in with
the London Times,
the Sunday Times a while back,
and it was unbelievably
stressful two weeks
because of that.
Cause you never know of
course how the public
is going to respond either.
And so far as I said,
I've been so fortunate
in people's response to me.
But I thought, well maybe
I've gone to the well
of public sympathy one
time, too many this time.
And it was undoubtedly
a mistake perhaps.
Oh, Christ, I don't know,
to have talked to
the Sunday times.
But I thought I had to talk
about what happened
to me to someone.
And we thought, well
they're hypothetically
stayed and reliable.
And it's hurtful to me
to see these institutions
become corrupted.
That I certainly take no
pleasure in seeing that.
It's appalling in
fact, to watch these
once great institutions
deteriorate
into tabloid style
journalism and deceit.
But no, the tour was
great Dave, I thought.
Jesus, I mean, it's complicated.
Because it also, my
life got so disrupted.
Because I was a professor and
I had my clinical practice
and my writing and a
business that I ran as well.
And now I'm not a
professor at the moment,
I'm on leave still and I don't
have my clinical practice.
And so I'm still...
I'm a drift to some
degree because of that.
Because that was
so much of my life.
And then of course the
tour filled that up.
And then, well there's
prolonged bout of illness.
My wife and then me.
I'm just starting to come
to terms with whatever
my new life looks like.
I think about going
back to the university,
but I'm not sure I can do it.
And that's very...
What would you say?
I don't know how to
think about the fact
that maybe I can't do it.
I'm certainly not
happy about it.
It's appalling.
- Do you mean because
of the physical rigors,
or just because you're-
- Yeah, yeah.
Just, I don't think my...
I don't think I'm
reliable enough
to take on that responsibility.
I don't know for sure,
but I'm still very ill.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't
even know how to ask this,
but I mean is there anything
else you wanna address
with any of that stuff?
I actually don't wanna
belabor the point,
but if there's
anything that you wanna
get off your chest
I know-
- We'll see how it goes.
No, I don't think so.
I mean, if it comes up
while we talk that's fine.
No, I'm so bored of it.
It's so dull and
appalling that we better
talk about virtually
anything else.
- All right, well, fear not,
I got a couple of things-
- I guess there is one thing
I should address Dave really.
Well, I've been an advocate
for people to put
their lives together
and of course my life
has fallen apart.
And so you might ask
yourself, well are you aware
of the irony of that?
And the answer to that
is, well, absolutely.
You know, it's shameful.
I feel that frequently.
And then, so you might say,
and people tweet this out
fairly regularly, who
am I to give advice?
And I suppose that's a
perfectly relevant question.
I guess I've always thought.
And I said this too, in the
lectures during the tour
that I don't really
think that what I'm doing
is giving advice.
Or if I am I'm also
giving it to me.
You know, it's
not like I believe
that I have all the answers.
I have answers that
I've found useful
while attempting to move ahead.
With this new book,
I can show you this.
That's what it looks like.
The black counterpart to the
white book, the previous book.
- Out today.
- I wrote a lot of it
while I was extremely ill.
And there were some
advantages to that.
I think in that I only
kept that material
that I felt was
reliable under duress.
Now I think probably,
perhaps my creativity
was somewhat compromised.
And so that may have
impacted the book negatively.
But it made for
more severe editing.
For example, the last
chapter is Be Grateful
in Spite of Your Suffering.
And certainly maintaining
that gratitude
is something I've
struggled with.
I think anybody who's
in pain chronically,
struggles with resentment.
But I know that
resentment poisons.
And I think
[indistinct] of courage.
And so I stand by
what I've written.
- You know, it's funny.
I would hear some
version of that.
People would ask me when
they would ask about you.
And they would say,
"Oh, well he was telling people
to get their lives together.
And here look what
happened to him."
And my answer was always
the same with people
which is, well, first off, he
never professed to be Jesus.
He never professed
to be perfect.
You actually, and this
is one of the things
that I think really helped
me throughout the tour.
You would often address
if you were struggling
with something.
From what I saw
virtually every night
gave a different
lecture every night.
And if you were frustrated
by something on a given day,
you would address it that night.
If something happened
with the media
or something was
happening personally.
And I think people, they
see us in these boxes
where people that write
books or whatever it is,
and they think that
we're supposed to be
perfect all the time.
Probably in your case,
certainly more than mine.
And it's just not something
that I ever saw you
say about yourself.
- Well, luckily, luckily...
And I'm really stunned by this.
You know, I thought
the other day
I'm gonna make an announcement
about the book on Tuesday.
I think that's March 2nd.
And I thought, well, what
do I wanna say about it?
And what I really wanted to
say when I thought about it.
I thought really what I
wanna do is thank people.
Because you know, this
criticism has come up.
And I think it's
a valid criticism.
It's like, who the hell
is he to talk about
getting people's act together?
I mean, everyone gets
ill and you know,
and everyone has
periods of their life
where things are going worse
than they might normally go.
But people have
been on on the whole
unbelievably patient with me.
And so I'm not sure why that is.
I mean, of course, I'm not
sure why any of this is.
Another thing I struggle with
is just trying to understand
what the hell is going on
generally speaking.
And why I've become such
a target for attention.
Both negative and positive.
Mostly positive.
Thank God.
I don't know how I could
tolerate it otherwise.
So I still really
don't understand it.
You know, I've been recently
I was reading some
material this week.
That's a anti-racist
math curricula.
And it claims for example,
that getting the right answer,
insisting that there's a
right answer in mathematics
is a sign of white
supremacy culture.
And that this isn't
some fringe publication.
Like the LA County of Education
has put its name behind.
It's funded by the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation.
And I do think that
the Gates Foundation
does some good work.
I've been thinking
about that again more.
And I think that we're
in a war on competence.
It's something like that.
We're certainly in a war
on the idea of competence.
That's why people
are criticizing the
idea of meritocracy.
But I don't think that
it's just a criticism
of the idea of meritocracy.
I think it's an assault
on the idea of merit.
And well we can
get back to that.
I don't think I've come up
with a clearer
formulation than that.
For some reason I'm
tangled up in that.
Well, I suppose because I
believe that merit exists.
- So do you see a
direct through line
to sort of what put you on
the map in the larger sense,
meaning Bill C 16 in Canada,
and you started
talking about that.
And you didn't want the
government to enforce
or restrict your
ability to speak freely.
This was people
pegged you as somehow
anti-trans or
something like that.
But you didn't want them
to be able to just tell you
what pronouns you
could or could not use.
Do you see a through
line from that moment?
And that's sort of when
I first heard about you.
This is now four
or five years ago.
To where we're at in terms of
the assault on STEM and the-
- There's some kind
of through line.
It eludes me that the
totality of the motive
for the culture wars eludes me.
But I do think assault on
the idea of competence.
It's a replay of the
Cane and Abel story.
Bitter attacks on...
It's motivated by
some resentment.
Some deep resentment.
And it's easy to be
resentful about competence.
The thing is though there's
lots of different
forms of competence.
You can allow
society to do exist,
where there's hierarchies
of competence,
as long as there's many of them.
And then people can thrive
according to their own ability.
And that's good.
As far as I can tell.
Everyone should be able to
capitalize on their strengths,
and strengths are
always relative.
And relative strength has merit.
The assault on merit
leaves, everyone bereft.
If people have relative
strengths which they do,
and if there is such
a thing as strength,
which should be something
like relative ability
to make a contribution
in a given domain.
That's what you trade on.
That's what you capitalize on.
That's what you have
to offer the world.
And his assault on
merit is an assault
on everyone's strength.
Because where you're
relatively strong
is where you're
relatively meritorious.
And there's a hard
drive to tear that down.
And it's driven by resentment.
And I'm tangled up in it somehow
well, so many people
are tangled up in it.
The whole political situation
seems radically unstable.
Far more so than two
years ago, I would say.
- You know, an awful lot
of people would say to me
over the last two years,
as the politics got
crazier and crazier,
"Man, if Jordan was around,
he'd be fixing
some of this stuff"
That's an unbelievable burden.
And yet I believe it to be true.
That I think when your
voice wasn't there
there was suddenly this hole
that none of us could fill.
And a lot of people who
I think were sort of
veering towards order, I think
oddly veered towards chaos.
- Well, it's very frustrating
not to be able to
participate fully.
And it's, I have a
very difficult time
coming to terms with it.
I'm doing what I can.
And I don't think this is over
by any stretch of
the imagination.
I really think that the tide
that swept through
the humanities,
and the social sciences
is going to sweep
through the STEM fields and
with far worse repercussions.
- Well, you can feel it coming.
I mean, you just mentioned
math two plus two
no longer equals four.
I mean, if we've lost
that, what do we got?
- And the document itself
is a very strange document.
I don't understand it.
- So I wanna ask you just
one or two more things
relative to our past
and everything we did.
And then I wanna
focus on the future
and I wanna focus
on the new book.
But two of the things that
you really moved me on,
and I wrote about it in
my book, both of them.
Well, one of them
was the core...
The idea of having
something to believe in
beyond just logic and reason.
And this became you had
several debates with Sam Harris
while in the midst of our tour.
I mean, you left to go do
these incredible debates.
But you completely
moved me on this one.
I definitely came from the Sam
Harris or the Steven Pinker
or the Jonathan Haidt
school of logic and reason.
Are enough to
organize societies.
And that's what humans have.
And after 100 plus
shows with you,
hearing it over and over
again, you moved me on that.
Truly moved me on that.
And I wonder if you think-
- What's the consequence
of that been for you?
- Well, A, I would say
that it's given me order
in the sense that I
can't control everything.
Not only can I not
control everything,
but I think this may
sound a little strange.
I think I have more respect for
the past, than I had before.
Where I thought I could sort
of figure everything out.
And figure out, certainly
what was best for me
and everyone about me
and all those things.
I still believe that, but
there's a context to it.
I guess that's what it is.
More than anything.
It gave me a context.
And a link to my ancestors.
Who I don't think I'm
necessarily so much better than.
You know, I think part
of the problem now
is that everyone seems to think,
"Oh, everyone who
came before you
was racist or backwards
or un-evolved."
And that the stories, I mean,
look you did all the
biblical lectures,
which I watched separately.
And why did you always
talk about Pinocchio
and wish upon a star.
That there is something else
that sits beneath our rationale.
And without that, the
rational mind is sort of lost.
You really moved me on that.
- Yeah, and I certainly
haven't stopped
believing that that's true.
In some sense we
live inside a story.
We live inside the hero
myth for better or worse.
And that doesn't mean it's true.
Because maybe the human
race isn't correct,
in some final sense.
But for better or worse
that's still our story
to forge a path
into the unknown.
To face the darkness, to
gather what's valuable,
and to disseminate it
among our compatriots.
That's us when we're
functioning properly.
And if the more you do that,
the more meaningful
your life is.
And that seems not to
be a trivial matter.
In fact, it's the absolute
opposite of trivial.
And I don't know what the
metaphysical significance
of that is.
And that's the final question.
The religious types.
I talked to Jonathan
[indistinct] and
Orthodox icon carver.
I've talked to him
quite a few times.
He's very devout,
Orthodox Christian.
Very very intelligent man.
We've discussed the potential
metaphysical significance
of the hero myth.
You know, how does it tie into
the ultimate nature of reality?
And I don't have
an answer for that.
The Christians believe that
the hero myth, so to speak
was manifest in its totality
in the figure of Christ.
And that's their explanation
for how the narrative world
and the empirical world touch.
And our whole culture
much of our culture
is predicated on that idea.
And it's a deep idea,
and it's not like I know
how to cope with the
paradoxes that it produces.
You know, I read
recently, for example
many people will know this.
That according to
current Catholic doctrine
the theory of evolution
is entirely acceptable.
I have no idea how
to integrate that
with classic Christianity.
The timeframes are so
radically different.
But I also don't think
that the empirical types.
The people that you mentioned,
this is the constant
discussion I had with Sam.
They haven't come to
terms with the fact
that we see the world
through a structure of value
and we can't get
outside of that.
- So is that why-
- Even to look at something.
- You said to me from the
day we started the tour
and you said it to me on
almost any given night.
You didn't wanna know the
questions that I was gonna ask.
You would always say
nothing's off limits.
Well, actually, what
you would usually
say to me is have fun
or have fun tonight,
something like that.
But I knew that the only
question that I sensed
and I probably only
asked you once or twice
once I realized it.
The only question that I
sensed you didn't wanna do,
because it would take
up too much time,
sort of was this.
Because when we would do the
Q&A, and we did it by an app
so people in the audience
could vote on them.
There would often be the, okay.
So do you believe in God?
What does that mean?
And it's sort of what
you're talking about here.
Once you whittle it all down.
We could do this for
the next six hours,
if not the rest of our lives.
- Well I've said
a lot about that.
I wouldn't say that my
thinking has really progressed.
I mean, beyond what I
had thought about before.
I try to conduct myself
as if God exists.
as if being is good.
That's faith, I suppose.
And I think to some degree,
that's also a kind of courage.
I mean, I'm not
claiming that my faith
is entirely courageous.
Because I waiver, of course,
and I've especially wavered.
I would say in the
last two years,
given everything
that's happened.
All the catastrophe
that's rained down
upon my family and I.
But I still believe that
you become corrupted.
If you become resentful
about existence.
You have to act as
if existence is good.
And that the truth is good.
Because otherwise
things get worse.
And so there's a limit.
There's limits past
which no one can see.
And the questions that we're
discussing are at the limit.
- Yeah, well that's
it right there.
The answer is not clean.
And I think everyone,
or so many of us
seem to want the
clean answer on that.
When you had those
debates with Sam, like,
"Oh that's the answer,
that's the winner,
that's the knockout blow."
And I think you're acknowledging
an uncomfortable truth.
- A friend of mine
the other day.
And he was raised at communist
in Poland and was an atheist.
And he went after
his family one year
for celebrating Christmas,
because it was logically
inconsistent with their beliefs.
Which it was.
But what he told
me when we walked
was that he came to
realize at one point
that all that meant was that
they would lose Christmas.
Yeah, it was logically
inconsistent,
but what are you gonna
replace this with?
And it's clearly the
case that people need...
You need beliefs to
organize your actions.
And then I see well what happens
when we don't turn
to more traditional
forms of belief,
as we turn to forms of belief
that are far more dangerous.
Or at least that lurks
as a possibility.
I also don't think it's that
easy for people to defend...
Like the rationalist,
for example.
They're not doing a great
job of defending the culture.
It doesn't sell well.
- No, they're doing a
horrible job, I would say.
I would say they're
doing almost no job.
That woke ism is in
many ways the end
of the purely rational, and
the purely secular order
ends with what we're seeing
now, in some ways I think.
- Well, let's hope not,
but it it doesn't seem to
be losing its momentum.
I don't think.
I mean, it's so hard
to get an accurate take
on the movement of the culture.
It still seems to me that
the education systems
are being corrupted,
from top to bottom.
You know, the
University of Kansas
closed its humanities
department a week ago.
Well, that's partly because
people aren't enrolling
in the humanities anymore.
So maybe that's...
Maybe the market in some sense
will correct some of this.
But it's proving very
difficult for defenders
of enlightenment values to
put up an effective fight
against this assault on
the idea of competence.
There's nothing solid enough
there for some reason.
And well, so here we are.
- That's it.
That's what belief sits upon.
All right, well, you know what.
Yeah, go ahead.
Well, let's dive into the book.
Because actually so
many of the things
that we're talking about
now are sort of part
and parcel to all of
the chapters here.
So chapter one, and what I
really liked about this also
is the way you organized it.
The new topics.
Because one of the
questions we would get often
in the Q&A that
you would get is,
"Oh, was there a 13th rule
that you couldn't
get in the book?
And you actually mentioned
this in the book.
That you had...
You had what?
About 46 other, was it 46?
- I had 42?
- 42.
You had 42.
- Yeah, the same
as Douglas Adams
Answer to The Universe, life,
the universe and everything.
42 rules.
Which was actually
a coincidence,
but I thought it was
comical in the aftermath.
There's 42 rules.
So now I've written about 20...
I've written essays
on 24 of them.
- When you got to 42,
how long did you give it
before you said,
okay 42 is enough.
Because I know you
you're pretty methodical.
- Yeah, I just did
it in an afternoon.
The original list of rules
I was playing on Quora.
I wrote about 40 answers for
Quora, something like that.
And I really haven't
partaken in that forum
for a long time now.
I was investigating it
and some kid had asked,
what do you need to know in
order to lead a good life?
Or what's most important to
know something like that.
And I thought, well, you know
I'll take a crack
at answering this.
And I made this
list of 42 rules,
and it got very
popular on Quora.
Much more popular, typical
Pareto Distribution.
Like that one answer
got more views
than all of my other
answers put together.
And so I thought that
was kind of interesting.
I had touched something
for some reason.
And out of that, when
I was asked by an agent
who contacted me, Sally Harding.
Of Cook Agency.
She asked me if I was interested
in writing something
more popular.
And I knew that those rules
had found an audience.
So that seemed to me to
be a place to dive in.
So anyways, I've only
written about 24 of them.
In the two books, I
have them both here.
You can see how
they're structured.
- Yeah, it's beautiful.
- One's white, and
the other is black.
They make a match set.
You can read each of
them independently.
And one concentrates.
The first one, An
Antidote to Chaos.
12 Rules for Life:
An Antidote to Chaos
does concentrate on
the consequences of
excess uncertainty.
And the second book concentrates
more on an excess of order.
Both of those are fundamental
existential dangers,
as far as I'm concerned.
And in this universe of
value in the world of value.
There are two major domains
and one domain is
the domain of order.
And you can
technically define it.
The domain of order is
where you find yourself,
when what you're doing
produces the results you want.
And that's a really
tight formulation.
Because it gives you
a particular idea,
of what a place in time is.
A place in time you
occupy at any given moment
is the place and time that's
defined by your current goal.
And you have a map of value
that guides you through
the actions that are
necessary in that domain.
And if the result
is what you want,
which brings motivation and
emotion into the picture,
then while you get
what you need or want.
But you also validate
your theory of existence.
Because it's good
enough to produce
the results that you desire.
And given that you're fallible
and that you don't
know everything,
you have to use proximal...
You have to use proximal truths.
And so something
it's a pragmatic...
It's a form of
philosophical pragmatism.
If you make a bridge
and it stands up,
then you know how
to make a bridge.
Why?
Because the bridge stood up.
Now, maybe you overbuilt it.
You could have built
it more elegantly.
But it's sufficiently true,
so that the bridge functions.
And we're like that,
we're like engineers.
We're cobbling together
solutions all the time.
And as long as those
solutions work,
we assume that we're right.
Well, that's the
domain of order.
The domain of chaos emerges
when you lay out a
plan and into action,
and something other than
what you wanted emerges.
And sometimes that
can be a catastrophe.
An absolute catastrophe.
And your brain, our
psychophysiology
is actually adapted
to those two domains.
When something
unexpected happens,
all sorts of emotions and
motivations break loose.
Fight and flight among them.
Anger among them.
It gets disinhibited.
Because when you don't
know what's happening,
you have to prepare
for everything.
So you get anxious and
then you hyper prepare,
which is extremely stressful.
And so the domain of chaos
is extremely stressful.
In small doses,
it's exhilarating.
And that's because,
well when you're aware,
you don't know what's happening,
you have the opportunity to
learn and to expand your map.
And so there's
always an interplay,
between the domain of chaos
and the domain of order.
But they can each pathologize.
And the pathologies of
uncertainty are more associated,
with anxiety and
nihilism and depression.
And where's the pathologies
of order more totalitarian.
And then I would say as
well, the liberal types
the more left leaning
types are quite sensitive
to pathologies of order.
They don't like them.
That's the patriarchy.
The patriarchy is the
pathology of order.
And it's symbolically masculine.
Something I've been taken
to task for claiming.
But the patriarchy itself.
The idea of the patriarchy
itself is a symbol.
The patriarchy is a symbol.
That's why it has such power.
And it's a symbol that refers
to the domain of order.
Now the domain of
order is protective
as well as oppressive.
But when it degenerates,
it becomes oppressive.
And I would say it
degenerates when it's based
on power rather than competence.
But it can be based
on competence.
The Marxist critics and the
politically correct types,
they insist that every
element of the patriarchy
is only a consequence of
the imposition of order.
Forceful imposition of order.
It's all power.
Well, no.
No it's not.
When it degenerates,
that's true.
You can tell that because the
thing is the domain of order
will be upheld by those who
inhabit it if it's functional.
If you have to use force,
that's already an indication
that it's become pathological.
Because people aren't
playing voluntarily.
- So, would you say we're in a
degenerative cycle right now.
That the cycle seems
more degenerative
than say a building cycle.
Or you think that that's just
the play that's always going
on and you have to figure
out your role in it?
- Well, I think the
play is always going on.
The antidote to
chaos isn't order.
And the antidote to
order isn't chaos,
the antidote to both is
the balancing of them.
The act of balancing of them.
- You used to do this a lot.
You would say the balance,
the struggle between liberal,
and conservative.
So people see me doing
this all the time.
I always [indistinct].
Jordan was talking about...
He was talking about this.
So you think that's it
- It's really
important to understand
that the antidote to chaos
in the final analysis
can't just be ordered.
Because order itself
can degenerate.
And so I believe that the
antidote is active engagement
with the world.
Honest active engagement
Truth.
And I think it's also
truth motivated by love.
Which is a motif
that runs through this
second book in particular.
And love is the desire for
all things to flourish.
Christ says that you
should love your enemies.
And what does that mean?
And it's really
worth thinking about.
It's you shouldn't
wish your enemies harm.
What I mean by that is that it
would be better for everyone
if they would conduct themselves
so that they would flourish.
And that doesn't mean you
shouldn't defend yourself.
It doesn't mean that
soldiers aren't necessary
or the police.
It doesn't mean any of that.
It's not a weak need statement.
It means that if you're...
If you have yourself pointed
in the right direction,
you don't wish an excess
of harm on the world.
You want it to flourish.
That's love.
So you weren't
yourself that way.
And I do believe that that
requires a certain courage.
Because the world is so
flawed and so painful.
There's so much suffering in it.
That it's very difficult
to fall in love with it.
You keep getting bounced off.
You think this is so terrible
that maybe it shouldn't even be.
But that takes you
down a very bad road.
So it's love first.
And then truth serves that.
And I do think that's the motif
that runs through the
old and new testaments.
The combination of
those two things.
Love is the desire,
that being flourish.
And I do believe that
truth serves that.
(indistinct chatter)
- Please finish your thought.
- Well, I also think that
people find meaning in that.
And everyone can answer
this for them self.
It's like you have to watch,
and you have to see where it is
that you find the meaning
that sustains your life.
And I would say, it's certainly
not been my experience
that people find that
in deceit or hatred.
I mean they may be
tempted by that.
They may have the reasons for it
but everyone is ashamed of that,
and wishes it
could be otherwise.
Even if they don't know
what to do about that.
So well, so this book,
the first chapter
is do not casually denigrate
social institutions
or creative achievement.
And I picked that
quite carefully
because again, the liberal
types are more likely
to criticize social
institutions.
So you don't wanna
do that casually
because they structure things
and protect you in a way
that you're likely
not even aware of.
And the conservative
always says,
look be careful when
you change something.
Because you're changing
a bunch of things
and you don't know
what's going to happen.
So be careful.
But social institutions
can become corrupt
even just as a
consequence of aging.
And so they have to be updated.
So they can't stay static.
But that doesn't mean you
shouldn't respect them.
And then creative
achievements on the other side
and conservatives, for example
they have a harder time with
open people, creative people.
The best personality
predictor of liberalism
is high openness.
Which is a creativity dimension.
Well, it's easy to
dismiss art, for example.
Especially if it doesn't
exactly speak to you.
But it's through
artistic endeavors,
through creative achievement,
that the process
of update occurs.
And so regardless of your
political temperament,
you need to see these forces...
You need to see the value
in these forces and have
some respect for them.
I think what happens
if you get educated,
hopefully is that
you get educated
beyond the confines
of your temperament.
- So that's why I
thought the ordering,
it's so interesting that you
said you intentionally...
of course intentionally did it.
So do not carelessly
denigrate social institutions
or creative achievements.
So that's chapter one.
And I thought it was
interesting because,
one of the things that
I've been talking about
for the last couple of years,
but especially in the last year.
And our friend Ben Shapiro
wrote a whole book about it,
is the disintegration of so
many of our institutions.
And that I think the
great debate right now
is can some of these
institutions survive,
or do we need all
new institutions?
Now, I know you're talking
about social institutions,
not just academic institutions,
or we're talking about
cultural institutions.
What do you feel
in that argument?
Whether can some things
just be left to disintegrate
and we rebuild, or do
we constantly end up
in a destruction and a rebirth?
Because right now we're
watching so many institutions
just crumble.
- Well, I tend to start
local when I'm thinking.
Because it simplifies things.
Well the first institution
is the sovereign individual.
We don't wanna let that crumble.
And the more that you're able
to live in a relationship
with truth, I would say
the better job you're doing
of protecting your integrity
as a sovereign individual,
start with that.
It would be a shame
to lose the family.
People derive a
tremendous amount
of the meaning of their
life from their family.
And then those
intense relationships.
I don't think we
can get beyond that.
I think you have to knit
your family together,
to the best of your ability.
And I know that people
often have terribly
fractured families.
But we don't have a good
substitute for that.
You need to exist in
relationship to your culture.
You need a job or a career
or something like that.
We need political institutions.
I think part of the
problem of course,
is that everything is
changing so rapidly,
that it's very difficult to...
It's very difficult to
say what should be kept
and what shouldn't be.
And we're not in control of
it to some degree as well.
I mean, there's
an all out assault
on the integrity of
cultural structures,
but there's also a technological
assault on everything.
And so what do you do in
a situation like that?
Well, I think my sense is
you revert to the individual.
You try to make better people.
- How much of this do you
think has to do with the speed?
Because actually I remember
on sort of the last
maybe quarter of the tour.
One of the things that
you talked about a lot
was how the internet
was changing us.
How the speed of
information was changing us.
How you as a random person,
no matter where you
are in the world.
You might be able
to send out a tweet
or create a meme that could
change the world like that.
So how much do you think the
speed is all part of this.
In ways that were literally
unimaginable three decades ago?
- I think it's a
tremendous part of it.
We don't know what
to do with any
of the new technologies
that we've produced.
And by the time we adapt to
them, they'll have transformed
into something
completely different.
So my kids are in their
late 20s and they're more
a part of the internet
generation than I am,
but they're being supplanted
in their knowledge
by younger people already.
They can both feel it.
It's changing
unbelievably quickly.
So that puts a tremendous
amount of stress on everyone.
- When you talk
about the creative
achievement part of this,
one of the things I've
been thinking about lately
is that I don't
remember the last time
I heard a new musician,
that I really loved,
or saw a piece of art that
was new, that I really loved.
You know, it seems so rare.
Because of what's happened
with cancel culture,
that the people that
should be showing us things
are not showing them.
What do we do about that?
How do we make the
artists brave again?
people who will give us
the creative achievement?
How do we make them
see that star again?
- Well you do whatever
you can, by example.
That's the best you've got.
So hopefully you try
to bring integrity
to your endeavors.
And hopefully that
has a salutary effect.
You don't have a better
option than that.
- So chapter two is,
imagine who you could be,
and then aim
single-mindedly at that.
And for me, after
being on tour with you,
I think that's something
that got into me
through osmosis.
That I would be on stage.
And even though everyone was
there for you, I thought,
"Hey I'm part of this, somehow.
This thing, somehow I
became part of this."
And then once I realized
that when the PA announcer
said my name, that
those people knew me,
I thought that I'm me.
I'm the guy you're
talking about.
I'm doing it.
And then just that
it helped my aim.
It helped my aim.
And I wonder how many
people just don't...
They don't know how to aim,
because they have no
experience like that.
Something like that.
- Well that's part
of what tradition
is supposed to teach you by
presenting you with examples
of great people of the past.
The lesson is not supposed
to be exactly bow down
and worship these people.
It's be like them, be like them.
And you could be.
And I mean, that's really
the goal of the humanities.
When it's the humanities.
If it's not, if that's
the goal, then students
will study the humanities.
As soon as that
ceases to be the goal,
then there's nothing
of value there.
I mean, great
literature tells you...
It tells you the great story
of good and evil, always.
It's good and evil
against a background
of chaos and order, always.
And the evil characters are
there to do to be bad examples.
And the good characters are
there to be good examples.
Or you see the interplay
of those forces within
a single person.
It's a reminder of
who you could be.
And you can find out
who you should be.
And this is something quite
mysterious, I believe.
- And part of the
proof let's say,
that we exist in
a world of value.
Your conscience tells
you who you should be.
Now that doesn't
mean that necessarily
that it's infallible,
but people wrestle
with their conscience.
- You know, there
isn't anyone...
I've never met anyone who is...
Narcissists accepted
it, let's say
people are generally
tormented by their conscience.
And the reason for that
is that they're not...
They're deviating from the
path that is their destiny.
And if you don't think that,
well then what do you think?
What do you think
that conscience is?
I mean, I've asked my
classes repeatedly.
Do you have a little voice
in your head that tells you
when you've done something
wrong or you're about to,
or a feeling, and they all
immediately agree with that.
No one finds that
a foreign concept.
And so if you don't know
who you are, your conscience
will remind you when you're...
Sorry.
If you don't know
who you could be
your conscience will remind
you when you deviate.
And then you can start
to attend to that.
Like well look, I'm actually
ashamed when I do this,
I should stop.
Unless I wanna be
ashamed all the time.
It looks like I should stop.
And then maybe you
stop doing that.
And then your conscience
objects to something else.
And maybe you
stopped doing that.
And as that happens you
start to develop a vision
of who could be.
And the chapter indicates...
It looks at symbolic
representations.
It's an examination of a
certain symbolic representation
of the ideal.
And so it's my attempt
to assess tradition
for what it can tell us
about what the ideal human
being might be like.
And the ideal human
being is the person
who forthrightly upholds
the traditions of the
culture and forges
a way into the unknown.
We went through that.
And pulls new information in
and rebuilds himself
and the world.
And that's who you could be.
And now the difficulty comes in,
figuring out how to do
that within the confines
of your own life.
So in some sense, that's how
to bring the divine to earth.
There's this divine pattern
But it's general.
See this is one of
the mysterious things
about Christianity,
that's so remarkable about it.
Is that there's the
Christ that's eternal.
The word of God say.
That's a representation
of something absolutely
transcendent.
But it's married
to the particulars
of one particular
time and space..
And obviously critics
of Christianity
regard that as one
of its major flaws.
That there's this idea of God
who was a carpenter in
some out of the way place,
in some out of the way time.
But you're someone in
an out of the way place
at a particular time and place.
And for you, what
that means is that,
for you to make contact
with the highest of values,
you have to bring that
down to your particulars
and figure out how you do that.
It's gonna be a way that
no one else does it.
Because you're the
only one that's you.
But you can aim at
something, aim at something.
And the point of the chapter
is you aim at something
and that will shape you
as you move towards it.
And then you're aim will
change, you'll move.
But that doesn't matter.
It gets you going.
And you'll be
molded across time.
More and more into the
person you could be.
- Can you talk about that
just from a personal perspective
as someone that I've seen do it.
I mean, that's what I
saw you do every night.
You would take your
intellectual curiosity
to the end of where it would go.
Sometimes you would get
off stage and say to me,
"Oh you know, I took that
as far as I could tonight."
And then the next
night you would go
a little bit further with
it, or a little bit further.
And I knew there were moments,
because we did so many shows.
I knew when you
were a little past
where you would wanna go,
and then I could
see you come back.
But can you talk about
what that was like for you
in terms of your life.
How you felt, how time felt.
How the relationship
with the audience felt.
When you're doing it right.
Cause I feel like
people don't know that.
When you're doing it right,
what does it feel like?
- Well, to begin with,
and this happened
when I was in graduate school.
I had a lot of bad habits.
I smoked like a pack
of cigarettes a day,
and I drank a lot.
I came from this little
town in Northern Alberta.
And like many little towns,
especially in Northern Canada.
Alcohol overuse is [indistinct].
And so I noticed when
I was in my early 20s,
that the only time
I really regretted
what I had done was
when I was drinking.
Now, it was also
interfering with me writing
because I couldn't
concentrate well enough
if I was hung over.
But I also couldn't really...
I couldn't tolerate
the emotional strain
of what I was writing
about when I was hung over.
I couldn't handle
being on the edge
because I destabilized
my nervous system.
In any case, I stopped drinking.
The reason for that
was, well I decided
I didn't want to be ashamed
of what I was doing anymore.
It seemed, I thought, well
maybe I could not do things
that were shameful, and then
see what my life was like.
So that was on the negative
end, the constraint end.
I think people get...
On the more positive end
people get deeply involved
in what they're doing,
if they're in the right
place in the right time.
So I would say, you can
tell, this is the idea
of heaven on earth
to some degree.
When time stops,
when you're not aware
of the duration of time.
When you're so engaged
with what you're doing.
That you're not aware
of the duration of time.
Then you've got
the forces of chaos
and order balanced properly.
You're not stultified and board.
That's an excessive order.
Everything's too predictable.
You're not overwhelmed.
You're dealing with...
You're playing tennis at
the peak of your game.
That's partly what
people experience
when they're great
athletes, when they play.
- The zone yeah.
- And they're always stretching
themselves to their limit.
You can tell that if you
watch a gymnast, for example.
Who has a brilliant performance.
They've stretched themselves
beyond their domain
of competence during
the performance.
And that's what makes
everybody leap to their feet.
That's the incarnation
given embodiment.
Right there in front of
you for some moments.
And everyone cheers that on.
- Do you think it's
weird how it becomes
a fleeting moment in a way?
I know what you're
saying is true.
When I'm doing what I'm
supposed to be doing,
and I'm on my game
and my thoughts
are right and straight.
Time just moves.
And then I go, "Whoa, a
month passed a month passed.
And I was good that whole time.
And I did write that whole
time and I was happier.
And my relationship with David
or whoever else is is
better in that time."
But that it becomes fleeting.
In that suddenly you
could have a great month,
and then suddenly something
happens, chaos returns.
It's that we almost
forget that moment.
You can't hold it.
- Well, it requires a lot of
it requires even to some degree
some good fortune to maintain.
I certainly haven't been able
to do that while I was ill.
One of the consequences
of my illness,
whatever it was or
is, was time dilation.
Days lasted weeks
it seemed like.
Minutes lasted hours.
And I mean that literally,
and that was terrible.
The weight of time, it's the
weight of brut mortality.
It's the weight of
self-consciousness.
And you escape that
immersed properly.
And that second chapter, it's
a pretty practical chapter.
It's like, well, if you're
not who you wanna be,
then think about how
you could better.
Take a chance, aim at that,
work at it and see what happens.
So that's a-
- And that's a disciplinary
routine I would say.
It takes you out of
your current order.
- I think that's also,
it's a perfect segue
to chapter three.
Which is do not hide
unwanted things in the fog.
Which seems to me, we live
in a constant state
of distraction now.
You've mentioned Twitter
a couple of times.
It's like is Twitter
bringing any of us happiness?
Or is it keeping us all in
a constant state of fog.
The overload and the endless
obsession with politics.
That all seems like a fog to me.
I do my August off
the grid and I do that
to get out of the fog.
- Yeah, distraction
is definitely fog.
And you'll distract yourself.
I think you distract
yourself mostly
when your conscience
is bothering you.
Because you don't want to
face what it is in your life
that it is uncomfortable.
That chapter is again
quite practical.
It's a reminder to pay attention
often to negative emotion.
Resentment, and
that sort of thing.
Because it can tell you...
Well, resentment is very useful.
Maybe maybe your partner
is talking to someone
and they're a little bit more
animated than you'd like,
and you get jealous.
And that jealousy is associated
with a whole set
of insecurities.
Or maybe they're flirting
and they shouldn't be.
It's not that easy to determine
and maybe you'll have
a big fight about that.
But you could just as well
pretend that didn't happen.
The emotion comes up, I'm
jealous, I'm resentful.
It's associated with experiences
like that in the past.
The psychoanalysts would
have called that a complex.
You could notice that.
You could think of, "Well
should I be jealous?"
Is there something
wrong with me?
Or there's something
wrong with my partner.
There's something wrong
with the relationship.
And you have to untangle that.
And who knows what
you'll have to untangle
to get that straight, or
you can bear the jealousy
and see what will happen
in the relationship.
Or maybe it'll disintegrate
because your
partner is flirting.
You ignore that.
It's not like you
repress it exactly.
And this chapter is an attempt
to distinguish repression
from this hiding in the fog.
It's that you get a hint
that something's wrong.
And then you have
to unpack that hint
to pull the information out.
So maybe your
partner is flirting.
And they shouldn't be.
And so then you have to find out
why they're dissatisfied
with the relationship
or what's tempting them.
Or what is crooked in
their soul at the moment.
or what they're
dissatisfied about.
Terrible journey of
exploration and discovery.
That's always presented as
something that's positive.
It's often not at all.
It's so hard.
It's like doing surgery
on a separating wound.
It's no wonder people avoid it.
But it's not helpful.
Because all it does
is leave that...
Those things grow and
multiply in the dark.
And if you ignore them,
they just cascade.
- Do you think that's just self
protection for most people?
That most people, they see it,
they know that
truth behind them.
Whether it's about their
partner or whatever it might be.
But they just...
It's just self protection.
Like, oh, I just got
to keep moving on,
as things are.
That we're just creatures of
habit or something like that.
- Sometimes it's that.
It especially gets to be that.
If it's accumulated
for a long time.
Because if you wouldn't have...
If you wouldn't deal with
it when it was a kitten,
you're not gonna deal with it
when it's a full grown lion.
But I think mostly it's...
It's something else I
return to in the book
is it's deceit,
resentment, and arrogance.
I already know what
I need to know.
That's arrogance.
Deceit is I don't have
to pay attention to that.
And resentment is, well,
things can go to hell.
And so can he or she.
And that's a pretty dark triad.
And you don't want the
spirit that embodies that
to take over your life.
That's for sure.
- Well that gets
us to four then.
I think you got the
order right on these.
Because chapter four is
noticed that opportunity lurks
where responsibility
has been abdicated.
Now I think we're seeing an
awful lot of that these days.
- Well, that's a nice inversion.
Because people are
often resentful.
If they see that responsibility
has been abdicated.
Why isn't that person
doing their job?
It's like, well,
hey man step in.
At your workplace
in your family.
When you think, well,
I shouldn't have to do
that extra work.
Well, you shouldn't be a slave.
You shouldn't allow
yourself to be tyrannized.
But if something bugs you
because the responsibility
is going unfulfilled,
there's a great
opportunity for you.
And this is something
I don't think
we teach young people well.
And one of the things
you may remember this
that was so striking
about the tour
was that I made a case
fairly consistently,
that most people find the
meaning that sustains them
through the
vicissitudes of life,
not in happiness, but
in responsibility.
And that would bring
everyone to a halt.
It would always make the
whole theater silent.
It's like, oh, I never
thought of that connection.
Because maybe you wanna
avoid responsibility.
And you can understand why.
You can understand why.
You hide from it.
Like Abraham, one of
the biblical stories.
Abraham, he stays in his
father's tent till he's like 80.
And then God gets fed up and
tells him to get the hell out
and grow up.
And everything that he
encounters is catastrophic.
He encounters tyranny.
The Egyptians conspired
to steal his wife.
He encounters
starvation and war.
That is what you encounter
if you go out in the world.
And you think who
the hell wants that?
I don't want the responsibility.
It's like, well, yes
you do, as it turns out.
There's nothing better
than responsibility.
Now I say that
with some caution,
I think that it's hard to say.
The responsibility
I've been overwhelmed
by my apparent responsibility.
But I think it's
also kept me alive.
And I mean that literally.
- Wait, can you go a
little deeper with that?
I mean, when you were
at your darkest moments
in the last two years,
whatever that might be.
Was it the feeling of-
- There's been many
times in the last year
where it would have
been much easier for me
just to be dead.
That's constant.
But no.
- But is it but no,
because of something in you
or is it but no,
because of the people.
That you would have abdicated
that responsibility.
Or is that ultimately
the same thing?
- Yeah.
Well, I do think that the two
aren't easily distinguishable
but it's definitely that.
It's definitely that.
One of the chapters,
the last chapter is Be Grateful
in Spite of Your Suffering.
You need a meaning to sustain
you through suffering.
And it is the case that you
find that in responsibility.
Well, and so it's good advice
for anyone who's at work.
You're resentful
about this and that
because people aren't
pulling their weight.
Pull it, see what happens.
You become
indispensable, instantly.
You'll know everything.
And maybe that job
won't be for you.
Or maybe that relationship
But you'll take your
hard acquired wisdom,
go elsewhere and flourish there.
So, this kid stopped me,
I think I wrote about
this in this book.
Kid stopped me in a restaurant
one day when I was walking in
and he said...
And he had an
undergraduate degree
and he was working as a
waiter in a chain steak place.
And he stopped me and
he said, "You know
about six months ago, I was
watching one of your lectures.
And I decided to stop being
resentful about my job."
And he was resentful because
he had a university degree
and he's working as a waiter.
Look, I don't have
anything against waiters.
It's like a waiter can
make your evening hooray.
He said, "Well, I decided
I'd start trying at my job.
Like really trying as
if it was worthwhile."
He said he got three
promotions in six months.
Like he's just rocketing
up the power hierarchy.
Well it's not power
it's competence
if it's well run.
And and places are
full of opportunity.
Now that doesn't mean
social structures
aren't sometimes corrupt.
But you can discover that too.
If you start to take
responsibility and
that goes sideways,
you're not being
credited with that.
Well, then that's an indication
that you need to restructure
the situation something's
corrupt about it.
Or if you can't do that, you
should go somewhere else.
Where that is valued.
It's a sign that
things aren't right.
If you bring your
best to the table
and that isn't appreciated,
there's something
wrong with the table.
Now that doesn't mean that
there's something wrong
with tables, always and
everywhere, but it is the case.
And this is something we
should all get straight.
When we think about hierarchies,
it's an axiom of the left.
That hierarchies are
predicated on power.
It's like, no.
Only when they're corrupt.
Well they're always corrupt.
Well, yes, that means
they're all hierarchies,
are contaminated with power.
Well, that isn't the
essence of the hierarchy.
The essence of the hierarchy
is distinction of value.
And you need the
distinction of value
because you can't
tell what to do.
Otherwise you have to do
the first things first.
That's a hierarchy of value.
That's not power unless
you're being compelled.
And then it's corrupt
and you should resist it.
- I'm reminded of...
I don't think I've thought of
this probably in two years.
But do you remember, we were
in one of the
Scandinavian countries.
I think maybe we
were leaving Sweden.
And we were sitting in the
first row of the plane.
And do you remember the guy.
It was a young black man,
sort of ran onto the plane.
He was wearing a yellow vest.
He was a worker working
the bridge or something.
And he came up to
you and he said,
"I'm not supposed to be
on the plane right now.
I'm not supposed
to say anything.
But you helped me
turn my life around.
I got this job because of you."
And what I remember more
than anything else is
he had this huge
smile on his face.
But it wasn't because you
told him to go out there
and be happy.
It was because you told
him to go out there
and fix some stuff.
And I think that's exactly
what you're talking
about right now.
- Those experiences
are so life sustaining.
It's so remarkable
to have that happen.
And that's something I've had...
I've been immensely privileged
to constantly experience.
Although there's also
something about it.
That's extremely painful.
You know, the magnitude of that
joy is sort of proportional
to the obstacles
it had to overcome
while it was attempting
to manifest itself.
You know, and one of the things
I'm sure you saw on the tour
and I don't know how
this affected you.
Was the depth of hunger
for encouragement
that exists everywhere
as far as I can tell.
And everyone wants
to be appreciated.
When they bring their
best to the table.
That's why the assault, the
current assault on merit
is so unbelievably brutal.
Because it will deny
everyone the right
to be appreciated
for being their best.
And well, you might ask,
well when does the
best become your enemy?
And that's easy.
It's when you flee from it.
Because the best then
tortures and tremendous you.
It's your conscience
or the judge.
And it's easy to see
that as a tyrant.
- I know that this one
was definitely in Sweden.
For our first show in Sweden.
I went to H&M to get a hat,
cause it was a windy day.
And I'm standing in line
and there's a young guy
standing in front of me.
And he tell...
I know I told you
this way back when,
but he told the cashier, he
said, "I'm buying my first suit.
This is my first suit.
I'm going to see Jordan
Peterson tonight."
And then the cashier said,
"I'm going to see Jordan
Peterson tonight."
And then I tapped the kid on
the shoulder that he saw me,
Oh my God, it's you.
And then that night at the show
I made a point of
calling him out.
I can't remember his name,
but he told me his name.
And I said in
somewhere here is Ben.
And he was at H&M and he's
in his first suit tonight.
And the entire audience
stood up and applauded.
And he was just a kid.
He was a kid.
And I thought, this is magical.
This is truly magical.
- Yes, well, it was such fun
to see people
dressing up for that.
People don't dress up
for anything anymore
and it's too bad.
- Well, now nobody
dresses up for anything.
No one goes anywhere.
But we actually
let's just talk...
Let's just talk about
that for a moment.
Just that.
I mean, beyond all
of the misinformation
about what they would
say about the audience.
It's 90% straight white men.
And it was usually 60,
40 maybe male to female,
but there were
trans people there,
there were black
people and gay people,
and all of that stuff, it's
not even worth going into.
But you always, I thought
were sort of fascinated
by that concept, that people
were dressing up to go there.
That that adds some extra
meaning to you I think
- Well it was just
fun to see that.
I had bought these suits.
I spent an inordinate
amount of money
on the suits that I
wore for that tour.
But I thought I was
gonna bring my A game
to the degree that
that was possible.
And that meant to pay
attention to every detail
that I could pay attention to.
And it helped.
I liked the suits.
I'm happy about the
fact that I did that.
Made that sacrifice
or took that dare.
And it was great to see
people put on their best self.
Even just to try it out.
- And they did it.
- There was a little game
that everyone was playing.
And it was lovely.
It was so lovely to see that.
And they looked good.
Man, they look good.
- They did, they look damn good.
You looked great.
Well, number five then
this seems obvious.
But I think a lot of people
don't don't fully get it.
Do not do what you hate.
- Well, we've talked about that
a little bit already.
That's a process of
self-realization.
It's like well maybe...
I think it's quite
common if are promiscuous
that they have
post-coital regret.
Now, I don't imagine
that everyone feels that
to the same degree.
And maybe there are people
who don't feel it at all.
You should probably watch out
for those people, I would say.
But perhaps not.
If that regret stays with you,
perhaps you should
examine what you're doing.
And I use that
example specifically,
because obviously sex
is immensely engaging.
And so it's
tremendously tempting.
But if the consequence of that
is the emergence of a state
of existence that you hate.
Well, maybe you shouldn't do it.
And it doesn't mean,
well, if you're...
It doesn't mean quit your
job because it's hard.
It means watch and see.
And if you hate
something that you do,
if it makes you feel small
and weak and sickened
and contemptible stop doing it.
That's your morality
speaking to you.
And this is why, again,
why it seems to me
there's many reasons
that morality,
it isn't merely
something that we create.
It has its existence.
Because when we violate our
own moral presuppositions,
we pay, we make
ourselves pay for it.
Why?
Why don't we just let
ourselves off the hook?
If there's nothing real there,
why bother with all of that?
- You know, one of the things
that I think about a lot
and I was going through
this during the tour.
But I was dealing
with alopecia areata
and I had lost huge
chunks of my hair.
And there was a night,
we were in Denmark
where I had this powder
that I would put on
to cover the spots.
I left my toiletry bag
in Sweden, I think.
And I had to run to the
place, and I had to...
Basically, they
didn't have powder.
I had to like, literally put
marker on my head to hide it.
I don't even know
that I had told you
about it at that point.
- No, not at that point.
- Yeah, I don't
think I had told you.
- It would have been
off the tour with you.
- Yeah, exactly.
Well actually you told...
When I finally did
tell you about it,
and that's also one
of those weird things.
Why would I have not
told you about it?
We all hold these weird things.
- You were embarrassed and you
know, that's not surprising.
We're very sensitive when
things mar our appearance.
- Well, then I finally
told you about it.
And you told me that you
actually had struggled with it
when you were younger as well.
But the reason I mentioned that
is now that I've conquered
it's all mine now.
Which is great.
I do think that at some level,
I thought it had only to
do with the amount of hate
that I was getting online.
And that caused a lot of stress.
But I do think at some level,
it also was being out of...
Out of either with
my moral compass
or my conscience or
some of the other things
that you're talking about.
- Being out of sync.
There's no doubt that
being out of sync
is psychophysiologically
stressful.
You know, if you're torturing
yourself with your conscience.
If you're at odds with yourself.
You're gonna experience
that in negative emotion.
Like anger, for
example or sadness.
Those are intense physically.
They're highly demanding states.
They'll do you in.
So it's certainly the
case that a bad conscience
can make you ill in
all sorts of ways.
Leave you open to the
invasion of pathogens.
Because your immune
system is suppressed
or as a consequence,
in a direct
psychophysiological consequence
of too much
physiological activity.
- You must've thought
about that for yourself
during some of your
health situations
over the last two years?
- Yes, definitely.
Like I said, I don't...
I still really don't understand
what's happened to me.
It's associated with some
immunological problem.
Which did manifest
itself at one point
when I was young in alopecia.
Which is an autoimmune disorder.
Other symptoms of
autoimmune disorder.
But I don't know.
And I certainly asked
myself to what degree
I'm out of sync with myself,
but I haven't been
able to sort it out.
I have the odd period of time
where my symptoms disappear.
The pain disappears,
then I'm fine.
As soon as the pain and
the anxiety disappear
I seem to get my
feet right away.
But anyways, it's an
bottomless mystery as far
as I can tell.
- Yeah, I think a lot of
people would find that
really interesting though.
When the pain, the
physical pain disappears.
That psychologically
you feel right now.
Cause a lot of people
just have unearned pain
from whatever physical
thing they're going through.
But that can sort of break
the mental part of this.
Or really hamper the
mental part of this.
- Yes, definitely.
If you break your back
in a car accident,
you're gonna be in pain
regardless of your state
of moral readiness, let's say.
- Right.
Chapter six, abandoned ideology.
I think we could all use a
little bit of this right now.
- Well, that chapter
is really an injunction
to allow yourself to think
in more complex terms.
It's useful to reduce
a complex phenomenon
to its simpler elements,
but it's not useful to reduce
it to the point of absurdity.
And so you can
explain hierarchical
function using power.
You can explain human
dynamics using sex.
Before I did that Marx did
it with economics, let's say.
You can boil down human
motivation to a single dimension
and then you can make
a compelling story
about why that's everything.
But it isn't everything.
Most things are multi-variate.
And a good example of
that is the wage gap
between men and women.
There's lots of
reasons for that.
Many, not one.
And it's much more satisfying
in some sense if it's one
partly because then you
can identify the enemy,
and you can not be the enemy
and then you can be good.
And so oversimplification
is satisfying.
You often don't have to
test out your theories
in the real world
to see if they work.
And it can give you an unearned
sense of moral superiority.
And so that's what
that chapter is about.
It's an injunction to allow
yourself to think complexly.
What is the cause of
poverty, for example?
Well, systemic
corruption is one cause.
(indistinct chatter)
well there's alcoholism,
there's drug abuse,
there's variation
in intelligence.
There's variation in
conscientiousness.
There's bad luck.
There's socioeconomic context.
There's education,
there's endless contributors.
Because poverty
is not one thing.
It's many things.
And you use it as a place
holder in conversation,
but you shouldn't
confuse that placeholder
with a homogenous category.
And etiology does that.
And well, it's a sign of
unsophisticated thinking.
- Do you sense that that's why
the woke ideology or
the Marxist ideology
that you were talking
about for so long.
Why it specifically
is so dangerous.
Because there is no play.
There is no ability to analyze
something in a different way.
Where we're generally-
- That certainly,
any of the old G...
If you really wanna
solve problems,
oversimplified solutions,
just get in the way.
And so then you end up focusing
on anti-racism in
mathematics teaching.
And that's not helpful
in all likelihood.
Or if it's helpful, it's
helpful in a small way.
- Chapter seven is work as
hard as you possibly can
at least one thing
and see what happens.
I know this one worked for me.
- Well, if chapter two was,
imagine who you could be.
This chapter seven, it
brings it down to earth.
If you don't know
who you should be
pick something, pick something.
Pick something that would
be an accomplishment.
Even do it arbitrarily.
Because maybe you
have too many choices.
You don't know what
you're interested in.
Start somewhere, aim
at something, do it.
Maybe it's a six month
certificate at something.
Maybe it's an online
course, whatever.
Pick something, work hard at it.
See what happens.
What'll happen is, well
you'll get more disciplined
as a consequence of the work.
And so that'll make you a
somewhat different person.
But also as you work on
it, you'll figure out
in more detail, why it's
for you or why it's not.
And then when you make
the next decision,
you'll be more informed.
That's how a self-correcting
cybernetic system
works essentially.
You establish a name
and you move towards it.
As you move towards it,
you gather information.
That may shift your aim.
But you have to move
towards the aim.
- So in essence, even
if you don't accomplish
what you set out to do
the lessons along the way,
that that is the higher
lesson at some level.
- Yes.
And let's say you should
try to accomplish it,
but let's say, while you
get halfway through it
and you think, I really
know this isn't for me.
then you might say,
well, how do you know
you're not just copping out?
And I would say,
well, you can set up
a check against that.
By swearing when
you start something
that you won't switch it,
except for something
more difficult.
Because everyone
has that tendency
to rationalize their
procrastination.
And that's a good
way of protecting
yourself against that.
I can quit this, but I
have to immediately...
I have to have a better plan.
That's more difficult.
And I can jump into that.
And this is also associated
with something like
the necessary minimum
of respect for tradition.
If you pick a goal,
it will be a goal.
That's a social institution
of some sort, virtually.
With virtual certainty,
because it has to be valuable
to other people to be
valuable generally speaking.
You wanna have...
You don't wanna be so cynical
that you stop yourself
from pursuing anything
because nothing's worthwhile.
That's not helpful.
And everyone knows that.
And you might say,
well, I can't get out
of that cynicism.
When I would say, well
jumping out of the cynicism
may be very difficult.
Try just doing something
local, just pick something.
If you don't have
a relationship,
make a dating profile.
You don't even have
to put it online.
But at least you
have the profile.
You're taking a step
in that direction.
And I've often thought
there's these seven things
that people have to
get approximately.
We went through some of them.
You need an intimate
relationship, family,
job or career.
You have take care of yourself
mentally and physically.
Your health.
You have to regulate your
drug and alcohol use.
You have to use your time
productively outside of work.
There's one other
I often mentioned.
I can't remember it now.
It's an arbitrary
list in some sense.
But if you don't have a
list, it's a good one.
And maybe you can pick one of
those things and work on them.
And if you have all
of those things,
your life is likely
to be better.
Maybe you're a true radical,
and you have to live in a
way that isn't traditional.
And you don't need any of that.
Highly improbable
that that's true.
And God only knows how you're
gonna find your own way.
But until you know
that for certain,
it's not such a bad idea
to adopt an apprenticeship,
in at least one of these areas.
And you know, the purpose
of being an apprentice
isn't so that you're a slave,
it's so that you become
capable of your masterpiece.
Of transcending the discipline.
So the idea is look,
there's lots of
disciplinary strategies.
There's lots of
games you could play.
And so you can fall into
a moral relativism say,
well all games are equal.
It's like, well, no.
But even if that's true, the
fact that you need a game
that isn't relative.
That's true, you need a game.
Pick a game.
Which game.
Anyone is better than none.
Play it hard.
See what happens, you'll
change as a consequence
of the pursuit.
And I think you have to be
in very dire straits before
that won't work.
You can be in straits
that are so dire
that you can't move forward.
But generally you're somewhere
that you could improve
in some manner.
- Is just getting
people to believe that.
Is that harder than actually
doing it in some ways.
That we seem to be...
There's so many young people
that just feel so lost.
That just getting them...
Just convincing them to do it
is in some ways more
important than doing it.
- I don't think you can
convince them exactly,
but you can ask them.
It's like, okay, well,
think about your life.
And I do think I address this
directly in that chapter.
Remember some time you
accomplish something difficult.
Well, was that a good...
Was that good or not?
And generally the
human experience.
As far as I can tell
is that when you've accomplished
something difficult.
You regard that as worthwhile.
So look, so then you say, this
is a therapeutic technique
in some sense, because you
don't try to convince people.
You get them to look at
their own experience.
It's like, well, it turns
out that in your life,
when you've done something
that stretched you
beyond where you were.
So that was difficult.
That you regarded
that as worthwhile.
Okay, so let's assume
that that's true.
And that, that
can be duplicated.
- Chapter eight.
I think I've done
a good job at this.
But I have to mostly give the
credit to David on this one.
Try to make one room in your
home as beautiful as possible.
See something around you.
- My favorite chapter.
- Yeah, well, you've got some
interesting artistic taste.
- Yeah, yeah, I suppose.
That's a chapter about
the value of beauty
as a marker for
the transcendent.
And it's great.
You wanna establish a
relationship with things
that sustain you.
Truth.
The great verity
is truth, beauty.
Beauty is difficult to define.
But it's an invitation to the
transcendent, essentially.
Because beauty
speaks of the ideal.
And it impacts you
beyond thought.
It's visceral beauty.
And that's an indication
of the power of the ideal.
And if you try to establish
a relationship with beauty
and so to do that, you
can make one corner
of your room
beautiful if you can.
You start to play with
the idea of beauty.
You start to learn
to discriminate
between what's beautiful
and what isn't.
And then you invite
that into your life.
And that's a scare...
That's a terrifying
thing to some degree.
Because beauty is very powerful.
Partly because it reminds
you of who you aren't.
But it's amazingly worthwhile.
And it's sort of the next step
beyond cleaning up your room.
You know make an orderly,
but then the next step
is make it beautiful.
And beauty is a higher
value than order.
- Yeah, do you sense
that most people,
maybe because of the speed
that we talked about before
are not putting the
primacy on this.
We see a lot of people
now on Skype and Zoom
and everything else.
And you see a lot
of people sitting
in some pretty
awful looking rooms.
And terrible drapes and
stuff all over the place.
So it is a connection to,
clean up your room in effect.
- Well, it's that.
Well, it's not easy and
it's very intimidating.
There's a story in there
about color on walls, paint.
My house now is much different
than it was a few years ago.
But it was 32
colors at one point.
And people are very
afraid of color.
They'll paint their house beige.
Because they don't want
their tastes to be on display
because then it's
subject to judgment.
And often that's wise,
because generally speaking
taste is very hard to develop.
I bought paintings on eBay
for a long time for a decade.
And the ratio of
terrible paintings
to good paintings is
unimaginably high.
It's like a 1000 to 1.
Maybe it's even
higher than that.
Almost everything is dreck.
And if you're a
beginning artist,
the probability
that you're gonna
produce something
spectacularly ugly
is virtually a 100%.
And by doing that,
you demonstrate
the appalling nature
of your relationship
to taste and beauty.
And that's very
intimidating for people.
And so that's partly
why it's so difficult
for artists to make their way.
Because if you're an established
artist, you have a name
and then people can buy your
art because of the name.
And then that validates the art.
If you're a new artist,
people have to rely
on their own taste
and then their own
taste is on display.
And that's terrifying.
And I'm not being
cynical about that.
I understand perfectly
well why it's terrifying.
But to establish a
relationship with beauty
is to dare something.
It's to dare establishing a
relationship with the divine.
If you're atheistic, let's say,
but you're hungering
for meaning,
or maybe even if
you're religious
and you're hungering
for meaning.
You can find it by establishing
your relationship with beauty.
And I think people
understand this.
I think music speaks it
most clearly to people.
Even people who have
terrible drapes let's say,
likely have a genre of music
they love that they
find beautiful,
that speaks to them in the
way that beauty speaks.
And music it's so democratic.
That's one of the things that's
so wonderful about music.
Is that virtually everyone is
affected profoundly by music.
And that's a good example
of the importance of beauty.
And the reality that emerges
when you establish a
relationship with it.
I mean, I do believe that
music is one of the things
that literally
keeps people alive.
- You know, I'm reminded
of many of the halls
that we were in, the
theaters that we were in,
they would have
pianos down there.
And sometimes I would
get to the theater,
an hour early and I'd hear
someone playing the piano.
And I quickly realized
after the first
or second time that it was you.
And you were usually...
You are usually
playing off your head.
I mean, these were just sounds
that you had in you, right?
- Yeah, well, I'm kind of a...
I really only know
three piano pieces.
They're all Beethoven, sonatas.
They're way beyond
my ability to play.
And I've tried to play
them for like 30 years.
And I can't play them now
cause I haven't played
them for two years.
But I got to the point where
I could play them badly.
But I could actually play them.
- You're being humble Peterson.
Come on, you were pretty good.
- Well, the improvisation
that you heard,
I know some chords,
not very many,
and I can improvise
within my limited domain,
of chord knowledge,
and that's quite fun but it
really is a narrow domain.
And I've dreamt of
expanding it, but I haven't.
And probably won't.
I'm so sensitive to sound now
that I can't play the piano.
I couldn't listen
to music for months.
It was a terrible loss.
Terrible loss.
It was too jarring.
And that association
with the beauty went.
It was like the river dried up.
The chapter's full
of poetry, not mine.
And so it's an aesthetic essay.
It's supposed to be beautiful.
I mean, I'm hoping that
there's some beauty
in all of the work...
In all of the book,
I always read my
sentences out loud
to see if they have a rhythm.
That's the poetic
element of writing.
So people who are out
there who wanna write,
that's something to
pay attention to.
Read your sentences out loud
and see if they have a rhythm.
I'm fortunate, I suppose to...
Do you know who
Akira the Don is?
- Of course, he's amazing.
The [indistinct] stuff with you
and a couple of the
other guys we know.
It's incredible, incredible.
- I get such a kick out of that.
And it seems that my
spontaneous speech has a rhythm
and he's been able to
capitalize on that.
And I watched that all the time
out of the corner of my eye
because it's such a
strange phenomenon
to be set to music like that.
But anyways
- How important do you think
is the creation part of it?
So some people can create
incredible sonatas,
and incredible paintings.
Some people can just
appreciate them.
Do you think it's important
that the creation part
is part of what
everyone does or no?
- I think it depends
on who you are.
I mean, look, openness
this personality dimension
that we mentioned,
creativity, essentially.
Very few people are
profoundly creative.
Just like very few people
are profoundly extroverted.
Or profoundly agreeable
compassionate.
There's variation.
And I've noticed this
in my clinical practice
because I've had
very open people.
They're probably drawn to me.
But I've also had
people in my practice
who weren't open at all.
And for them creativity,
isn't very important.
It isn't where they
draw their nourishment.
Now that doesn't mean
they couldn't establish
some relationship with beauty.
And I suspect that
for some people,
that's a better pathway
than for others.
For open people aesthetic
beauty is bread and butter.
It's not optional.
And that may even extend
to the creating aspect.
They have to create.
That's who they are.
Just like an extrovert has
to go to social occasions.
That's who they are,
that's their niche.
But I think that beauty is...
If you can establish a
relationship with it,
so much the better for you.
And I suppose for
everyone else too.
Because then things
become more beautiful.
It would be wonderful if we
paid more attention to that.
Because so much
of what we create
is one of the things
I'm so stunned
that stuns me going to Europe.
Because so much of the
old European cities.
They're so beautiful that
they stop your heart.
And you just can't say that
about most modern cities.
That's gone.
Or most modern landscapes.
It's utilitarian and efficient,
but it's by no means beautiful.
And it's a catastrophic loss.
You think of the economic
value of the beauty
that's in Europe.
And the tourists that flock
there, in the millions,
the tens of millions to immerse
themselves in that beauty.
Even not knowing why
they're doing it.
It's their communion
with the divine.
It really is.
- I mean, just to
walk around Oxford,
which I think we
did two shows in,
and then I went for the the
speech at the union there.
It's extraordinary.
It's actually mind blowing.
You cannot believe that
people put this together.
- Yes, exactly.
And then that tells you
something about people.
Doesn't it?
Look at what we can do.
Look at what we can manage.
And that's such a gift
to be immersed in that
and to participate in that.
And so that's chapter seven.
- So chapter...
So that's actually chapter
eight, and chapter nine.
Chapter nine, I thought this
one was really interesting
because this I think may be
came up more consistently
in the Q&A than anything else.
If old memories still upset you,
write them down
carefully and completely.
There was a lot of questions
related to this sort of thing.
Where people would
say, okay, Jordan,
I've followed the 12 rules and
I'm not an alcoholic anymore.
I'm off drugs.
I've healed this relationship.
I got a better job.
Some version of all of that.
But what they would often say.
And I think I talked
to you about this.
Sometimes with myself.
I still felt guilt about
things from the past.
Even though my life
had moved past them.
And you would always say,
well you should do the
self-authoring program.
Which I did do.
But that in essence is
what you're saying here.
I think as well.
- Well, if something still
has emotional resonance.
So it's plaguing you,
it's, possessing you.
You can't let go of it.
It's your baggage.
You don't wanna think about it.
Look, if you're in the
midst of a catastrophe,
dwelling on the catastrophe is
not necessarily a good idea.
I'm talking about we could
use as a rule of thumb
things that happened
more than two years ago.
That would be safe.
Because otherwise maybe
they're still going on
and you're immersed in them
and you can't make
sense of them.
And dwelling on them just
makes the catastrophe worse.
Old memories, things, you
know you should be over.
If they're still
emotionally resonant.
Especially if the
emotion is negative.
Anger, fear, hatred,
resentment, something like that.
Then there's information
locked up in that
that you haven't unpacked.
And what that means.
See, because you build yourself
out of the information,
that you encounter in the world.
What that means is that
part of you is still stuck.
It's as if part of you is
still stuck in that experience.
Or it's as if there's
territory that you traversed
that you haven't mapped.
And so you might fall
into the same hole again.
And your emotions
are indicating that.
They're saying
there's danger here.
There's danger here.
There's unprocessed danger here.
Attend to it.
But you don't want to.
And no wonder, you
have to dig into it,
and then you have to map it.
And your map is effective
when you've rearranged
your perceptions
or your behavior.
So that that event is unlikely
to occur again in the future.
That's really the
purpose of your memory.
Is you remember things
so you don't make the same
stupid mistakes again.
That's the pragmatic
utility of memory.
And so you see this to some
degree in psychotherapy.
The [indistinct] in particular
emphasized past trauma.
And you can emphasize
that far too much.
It's not as if a
therapeutic process
should be necessarily obsessive
concern with your childhood.
But if you're still
plagued by memories
you can't let them go.
They're not mapped.
It's an indication that you
have not fully mined the...
You have not fully benefited
from what you've been offered.
There's wisdom laying there.
And so you can do that
by writing this happened
this is what I remember.
This is how it makes me feel.
Well, why did it happen?
What could have I
done differently?
What's the significance now?
Am I misinterpreting this?
There's a lot of clinical
stories that I modified
because for no concern
for my client's privacy.
But I kept the stories intact.
You reconfigure your personality
by dealing with what you
have not yet dealt with.
And then it stops interfering
with your present.
It might be that you
view your current...
The person you have a
current relationship with
through eyes that
have been affected
by a multitude of
relationship failures.
And so you're projecting
assumptions onto this person
and because you've been hurt
and you have to
untangle all of that
before you can get beyond that.
And so you catch up
with yourself that way.
So that's what that's...
That's an injunction to do that.
To clean up your house.
- And if you don't,
it leads to a lot
of the other stuff
that you've been
talking about here.
Number 10.
Well, it sorta works off
the relationship part
that you just mentioned.
Plan and work diligently
to maintain the romance
in your relationship.
You know, one of the things
that I consistently saw
on the tour is that you and
Tammy really love each other.
And there was a lot
of struggles there
obviously with her
health at first.
But it was just obvious the
way you behave towards you...
You know, after
every single show
I usually go into the
green room with you.
We do a little download
of what happened.
And then immediately
when Tammy would walk in,
you'd say the same thing every
night, how was it tonight?
And you meant it.
You wanted to know,
she's the most important
person in your life.
And you wanted to
know what she thought
of what you just did.
And that was important.
- Yeah, and we're
still together.
Despite I feel bad
for her unfortunately,
having to live with
me at current time.
It's very difficult.
And she's certainly been
through her own hell,
but has come out of it intact.
So this chapter.
Romance is like beauty.
It's grace, it's a gift.
But you have to work at it.
It's a gift sometimes,
you fall romantically
in love with someone.
And there'll be the
romantic adventures
that go along with that.
But it's only a gift
for a short time.
After that it has
to be something
that you strive to attain.
And even in the initial
phases of a relationship,
you strive, you put
your best foot forward.
If you're trying to
impress the person.
You could say, well,
that's being false.
But well maybe it's
allowing who you are
to shine through briefly.
If you're not a complete
psychopath, and manipulative,
you put some effort into it.
And then you think,
well, I've fallen in love
with this person that
should just continue.
It's like that
isn't how it works.
You have to...
Just like if you want
your room to be beautiful.
You have to buy
paintings and art
and furniture that's
functional and beautiful.
And you have to work at it.
You have to attend to it.
And romance is the same thing.
It's vital, but it's delicate.
It's a form of play.
And play in children.
If any other motivational state
emerges in a child's psyche
they'll stop playing.
Hunger, thirst, they're tired.
They're hot, they're cold.
They're lonesome.
All of that will disrupt play.
Even though play is vital.
And romance is the
adult form of play.
And the conditions have
to be set up for it.
And so when I was
doing my clinical work,
I would say to my clients,
Well set at least one
evening a week aside
for a romantic adventure.
And then figure out what
that's gonna look like.
What would you like?
Well, then you have
to ask yourself,
"Well what is it that I
would like, what do I need?"
And then that's
often real difficult
because you won't even admit it.
You wanna keep it in the fog.
You don't wanna have the
fight with your partner.
discussion with your partner.
You don't want to light candles.
You feel foolish.
You don't wanna put on some
clothes that are semi attractive
because you're embarrassed
about your body
or whatever it might be.
This is all extremely difficult.
But you can get better
and better at it.
And maybe it can be more than...
Hell do it once a
month to begin with.
And do it badly.
Allow your partner to be crabby
and not fully immersed in it
until you get good at it.
You might have to do it 40 times
before you're even
vaguely good at it.
Like anything else
that's complex,
but you might as well do it.
And then maybe you
can keep the mystery
of your partner
alive to some degree.
And you won't be so tempted
to find your romantic
adventure elsewhere.
- You know, it's funny,
this may not be the exact
example you're going for here.
But I know and you
got to spend some time
with David as well.
We've been together
for 10 years.
If I can make him laugh still,
which I try to do every day.
And I'm usually
pretty good at it.
It's like, to me, that's
the greatest thing.
Like, wow, after 10 years, this
guy still thinks I'm funny.
Like he knows all my tricks
and he still thinks I'm funny.
That's pretty good right there.
- Absolutely.
Well, that's a form of play too.
And Tammy and I put a
lot of effort into that.
And it definitely paid off.
And we put ourselves
on the line.
She's quite
confident physically.
Much more so than I was.
Probably much more
so than I still am.
And that was very helpful to me.
But then it's another situation
where you can imagine
you could have the
perfect romantic evening.
Well, you could maybe.
It's not gonna be easy to get
to perfect that's for sure.
But you could get to a
reasonable approximation of it.
And why not?
You don't have anything
better to do than that.
So that's that chapter.
It's very practical.
The book is like the
first book I thought.
I try to discuss things at the
highest level of abstraction.
Even religious level
of abstraction,
but it's all very practical.
- It's unbelievably
practical actually.
And I think that's the secret.
Two more.
So chapter 11 is, do
not allow yourself
to become resentful
deceitful or arrogant.
So there's sort of
been a through line
through a lot of the other
chapters that have fit this.
But it ain't easy.
Even when you
know, you shouldn't
- That chapter, I try
to deal forthrightly
with the domain
of human problems.
And that's the
mythological landscape.
There's utter chaos when
everything falls apart.
And that's symbolized often
by the dragon of chaos.
An unbelievably ancient symbol.
And it's a symbol of everything
that conspires against us.
It's a symbol of malevolence
and evil, of predation.
And it's also a
symbol of possibility.
And it's complicated.
And so I won't go into it.
But dragon's hoard treasure.
and that's enough said.
And everyone knows that
even though it doesn't...
It's a paradox.
It's not logical,
it's a paradox.
It's the coming
together of opposites.
So there's that.
There's the utter
chaos of existence.
Then there's the natural
world conspiring to do you in
at every level constantly.
And that can be cancer,
which is life gone astray.
It can be all the horrors
of the eating and the digestion
and the reproduction and
the whole horrid mess
that's biology and that
we're subjected to.
And in the beneficiaries of...
And then there's culture,
which is crushing you constantly
to be a cog in the
functional wheel.
And then there's
your own black heart.
And all of those things
can twist you against life.
And no wonder that makes
you resentful and no wonder.
It's no wonder it's a miracle,
that you can avoid that,
but there's nothing
about it that's helpful.
You become arrogant,
you can't learn.
You become resentful.
You make everything worse.
You become deceitful.
You corrupt being itself.
It's so tempting.
And so I outlined why it's like,
"Look, here's what we face."
It's bleak, it's bleak,
but it's not only bleak.
We all die.
We have to deal with
self-conscious finitude.
And the knowledge of suffering.
And the knowledge of injustice
and tyranny, all of that.
And human evil.
- What, that's it.
- There's nothing good
down those pathways.
Resentment in particular.
I think resentment is
unbelievably useful.
And so for practical purposes,
for everyone who's listening.
If you're resentful
about something.
Well first of all, you
should notice I'm resentful,
and that's kinda humiliating.
Because no one's proud
of being resentful.
It's a shameful emotion.
So then why are you resentful?
Well, there's only two reasons.
As far as I've
been able to tell.
One is that you're
allowing yourself
to be taken advantage of
or you're being
taken advantage of.
Sometimes you're not
allowing yourself.
Sometimes you're a child
being abused by their uncle.
You're not allowing yourself.
You can't do anything about it.
You're resentful because
you're being taken advantage of
or because you're immature.
It's one of those two things.
Figure out which it is.
And then take the steps
necessary to address it.
Living a life without
resentment is a great goal.
You watch people
drop the resentment.
They get younger.
They get visibly younger
when they drop it.
It's amazing to see that.
I saw that my clinical
clients all the time.
They'd be resentful
about something.
Their face would
harden, they'd get old.
And then they'd let it go.
And sometimes that was
accompanied by tears.
And you have to let it go lots.
Just once won't do it.
But they'd let it go
and then they'd be calm.
And their face would be
unlined at least for a while.
They'd sort of return to a
childlike state of trust.
Or they would retain that.
That's a better way
of thinking about it.
- Yeah, and then you can be
happy for people around you.
Which was one of the...
One of the rules
in the first book.
And I remember when I...
I'm sure you remember
this when we were in Oslo
and I walked into
the room and I said,
"Jordan, I just got a call.
I got a book deal."
And you were sitting
in a swivel chair
and you slapped
your hands together.
You spun around in
the chair, you got up,
you had a huge
smile on your face.
You hugged me, Tammy got up.
She had a huge smile.
David came in, everybody hugged.
And it was like, you
were genuinely...
I mentioned a couple
of times in the book
when I saw you live
up to the rules.
But it was like you
were genuinely happy.
There wasn't resentment.
Like, "Oh, now this
guy got something."
It was, this is great.
- Well God, wouldn't
it be lovely
to be able to enjoy
someone else's happiness.
It's like, it's happiness
is precious and rare.
And why deny yourself that?
If it's from someone
else thank God
they get a break from their
catastrophe of their life.
And wouldn't it be wonderful
if that was happening
all the time.
You close yourself off
so badly being resentful.
Because everyone
else's good fortune
is equated to your misery.
How terrible.
And that's part of the
pathology of this insistence
that our culture is
nothing but a tyranny.
If that's the case, then
anyone who attains anything
within it is only a tyrant.
And then makes everyone's
accomplishments, an imposition
and theft from everyone else.
How awful.
- Well you've been setting
it right for a long time.
And I guess that brings us
perfectly to chapter 12.
Which is be grateful in
spite of your suffering.
And I think you probably know
a little something about it.
- That's courage.
That's courage to be grateful.
To remind yourself.
I say grace with my
wife every night.
And I need to do that.
I actually think in some ways,
it's the best part of my day.
Strangely enough.
Although that's not saying much.
It's very useful to remind
myself to be grateful
and the worst your situation,
the more important
that is paradoxically.
Because you can have
a terrible situation.
And then also be
ungrateful, be resentful.
And then it's worse.
It's much worse.
So it's courage.
What do I have to
be grateful for?
And to maintain that.
That's better for everyone else.
So that chapter is hard on me.
It's sort of
traumatic to read it.
Because I struggle with it.
Because I'm in pain
most of the time,
but I know that it's not
helpful to be resentful.
It's better to be grateful.
And you can do that
without being naive.
It's an act of will.
Or at least something
to practice.
So that's the book
- Jordan, I love you, man.
You helped me turn
my life around,
because of the things that
you were courageous enough
to put out in the world.
And I'm honored and humbled that
I was this much of the adventure
of the last couple of years.
And I'm beyond thrilled.
- We had such a good time.
- We did man, we did.
That's why it feels like a
dream because it was just...
John, our tour manager
he used to always joke.
He'd go, "This is the most
boring tour I've ever been on."
Nobody's wrecking hotel rooms,
and nobody is
beating anybody up.
And I think our
running joke was that
the worst thing that
happened on the entire tour,
was we were in Calgary.
And I accidentally said
that we were in Edmonton,
which they were not happy about.
- No you were in Toronto.
- Was I in Toronto.
- Even worse.
- Right, those two or
at least Western Canada.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, you committed a
cardinal sin for a Canadian.
- But truly Jordan.
It's just so good to
talk to you again.
And I can't wait to
see you in person.
And I'm thrilled
that you're back.
- When we're out
of this COVID hell.
And hopefully everything
returns to everything we had.
When everything was normal.
I walked down Queen
Street in Toronto.
Kind of a trendy area,
populated by galleries
and restaurants and
little independent shops.
Where people have
poured their heart into
and they're all shuttered.
Every fourth business
is shuttered.
And you see the
dreams that people...
And effort that people
poured into these businesses.
It's heart-wrenching to
see that all taken away.
I'm amazed that people...
I'm amazed at how well
people have done with this.
I can't believe that
things haven't fallen apart
more than they have.
I don't know how
people are managing.
But maybe we'll get lucky
in these vaccines will work
and we'll get what we had back.
And maybe we'll be wise enough
to appreciate it a bit more.
That would be good.
- When that be something.
If we could only be appreciative
of what we had a year ago today,
before it all kind
of fell apart.
- That would be
something, all right.
- Jordan, welcome back.
Welcome back and I-
- Good talking to you.
- I hope we can continue
on this adventure together.
And it's good to see a smile.
I'm thrilled you're back.
So thank you.
And obviously the link
to the book is down there
and all that good stuff.
And please send our love to
Tammy and the whole family.
If you'd like to see more honest
and insightful conversations
with Jordan Peterson himself.
Check out our Jordan
Peterson playlist,
which includes every interview
I've ever done with him.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
both are right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.